- What do you feel like separates
this "John Wick" from the previous three?
- I feel like for the first
time, we see Ian's character...
- [Kelly] Vulnerable?
Or not vulnerable but--
- Where it gets personal for him.
- Yeah.
- And his trajectory
throughout the rest of the film
is about loyalty and friendship
and, for the first time, revenge.
- And how sneaky he is.
- Well I think yeah, but also I think,
you know, they have a deep love for John.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I mean like if he was--
I think if you asked anybody
their top list of assassins,
he would be number one.
- Yeah.
- Well and the person,
like they're a fanboy,
but he's like, he is.
But this also goes deeper than that
'cause you don't quite never know
what the relationship between me and--
- [Kelly] But there's such--
- Keanu is in the--
- a loyalty and a backstory.
- Absolutely.
- Yeah.
- And him,
we feel protective of him.
And when at the beginning of this movie,
you know, my world is taken away from me.
- I know. That's what I'm saying--
- That's where it becomes--
- Your character, yeah.
- As you said in episode one,
"This time it's personal."
- Personal.
- And also in addition
to just how incredible--
I mean, when I watched the
film, I was struck by how--
I mean, every one of
these films looks great.
But how incredibly beautiful the entire--
especially a film that moves so much
and has so much almost relentless action.
It's just stunningly gorgeous to watch.
But the other thing for
me is the theme of--
family's such a huge theme
in this particular film,
more than any others, and-
- For y'all and for your individual-
- Well yeah, I was gonna
say literal family,
but also you see with the three of us
how it's not just the family
that you're born into,
but the family that you've created,
and how much we really are family.
- Yeah.
- Also, the fact that Chad
has done all four is very, very important.
Hugely important.
- It's a common thread.
- And he and Chad
have worked together for, you know...
- Since The Matrix.
- Coming up probably 30 years,
over 25 years, yeah.
So there's a deep
understanding of each other
and a deep empathy for the story.
And Derek Kolstad wrote something
which I think you've been very true to
and expanded upon in a very mature way
and in a very, you know, adventurous way.
It's just a shame we can't--
I can't kill anymore people.
- Yeah. Well you're sneaky.
Let's not get past that.
- [Lance] Yeah. Yeah.
- I was like,
oh with the twist!
- No, I say it though.